hey if you want to support this channel
and get exclusive anime merch at the
same time check out our brand new online
store we have original designs like this
inés the world is yours shirt created by
pro artist Cuusoo mati you can't find
these designs anywhere else so check us
out at anime out Broadcom link in the
description
fans of the channel feel free to use a
special discount code uproar 25 at
checkout for an instant 25% off
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about goblin Slayer I'm a fan so
I wanted to make a video about it as we
wait for the next episode if you're also
a fellow fan and would like to see more
goblin Slayer videos in the future
definitely slay that like button like it
was mean and green and if you haven't
make sure to subscribe and ring that
magic youtube bell to join the strongest
goblin slaying team on youtube the witch
from episode 3 really wants you to do it
also if you have any suggestions for
future goblin slayer videos you want to
see definitely drop them in the comments
now without further ado let's jump into
the facts fact number one Kumo kagu the
author of goblin Slayer started writing
online much like Koganei Maruyama the
author of overlord he published smaller
parts of his story at a time
like a chapter and then got instant
feedback from his fans eventually he got
discovered and SB creative published the
first volume of goblin Slayer on
February 15th 2016 in the form of a
light novel
if you don't know light novels or books
that are usually about 50,000 words long
about the length of the Great Gatsby and
includes a manga style illustrations in
the book like manga successful ones are
often adapted into an anime the
illustrator for the light novel is
Noboru khanna - key for kuhmo the author
it was strange for him to write such a
long project without the instant online
feedback he had become accustomed to so
he regularly turned to his friends for
feedback while working on the first
volume so far eight volumes of the light
novel have been released in Japan and
five of these have been officially
translated and published in English in
addition to these volumes one more like
novel was released a side story called
goblin Slayer side story year one in
March 2018 I am very interested in this
story because it is also written by the
same author and it revolves around
goblin Slayer and when he was just
starting out as an adventurer I can't
wait to read it and you can actually
pre-order the official English
translation now on Amazon it'll be
dropping October 30th 2018
fact number two
along with the light novel volumes there
are also multiple manga offshoots of
goblin Slayer the main manga adaptation
is drawn by Cascadia dasa and is
published in monthly big Gungan magazine
which focuses on seinen manga seinen
literally means youth but it's an older
demographic than shown it while Shonen
manga are mainly geared towards guys
from around 12 to 18 say men manga are
mainly geared towards guys in their 20s
to 50s anyone who has watched the first
episode of goblin Slayer probably
understands why it fits into the latter
category especially since the manga is
even less censored at the anime 5 manga
volumes have been released so far in
Japan and three of these volumes have
been released officially in English
besides the main adaptation a goblin
Slayer side story year one manga has
been released based on the light novel
of the same name lastly if you are a
hardcore goblin slayer fan you should
also know that the first chapter of the
Goblin Slayer brand new day manga
spin-off was released on May 25th 2018
and this ongoing manga follows the lives
of minor characters and further explores
the world that goblin slayer takes place
in all of these adaptations make it
clear that goblin Slayer is very popular
and right now it seems like people just
can't get enough fact number three let's
talk about the anime goblin Slayer was
adapted by the animation studio white
fox this is a perfect fit
since the studio focuses on adapting
dark fantasy light novels and other
dramatic amateur content and goblins
slayer is definitely mature white fox
release entertaining and financially
successful anime like reezy row and
steins gate which is one of my favorite
anime of all time so let's just say that
as far as Studios go I have my hopes
high for this anime adaptation and I
think they've been doing a great job so
far
furthermore the director taka Haru Ozaki
also worked on our easy row and even
Cowboy Bebop albeit he wasn't the
director but still if you contributed to
Cowboy Bebop in any way that's gotta be
a good sign all things considered
there's reason to have faith in this
anime adaptation also if we can go by
the overlord formula which uses three
light novel volumes to create one
12-episode anime season
then we should almost have enough light
novel material for three 12-episode
anime seasons of goblin slayer
man that must be a lot of goblin slang
fact number four next we turn to kona
light novel GAO Sugoi translation this
light novel is amazing which is an
annual light novel guidebook which ranks
the top ten light novels of the year
according to readers pulled on the
internet this annual magazine is a
pretty big deal for light novel fans and
many of the light novels featured in it
were turned into anime like sword are
aligned kono Suba re0 and overlord to
name a few in 2017 goblin slayer got
fifth place in its category beating out
kono Suba which got ninth and scoring
just behind sword are online which came
in 4th place and it did all this without
anime height now with the anime finally
out I wouldn't be surprised that goblin
Slayer appeared on the top 10 list again
in 2019 perhaps even scoring higher than
5th place I guess we'll just have to
wait and see fact number 5 a big source
of kumo inspiration for Goblet Slayer
comes from classic fantasy novels rather
than being influenced by current works
Cuomo admits that he is more heavily
influenced by older fantasy stories
which is likely why his main character
unlike so many other main characters
today is actually from the fantasy world
and not just a modern-day person trapped
in a virtual fantasy game j.r.r tolkien
who wrote classics like The Hobbit and
The Lord of the Rings book series
appears to be one of kumo influences for
instance high elf Archer calls goblin
Serra orc bull when asked what it means
she explains and I quote it's the name
of a sword that appears in our legends
it was a goblin sling blade that would
glow blue when an orc a goblin was near
in the hobbit there's a similar blade
called or crest it was made by elven
Smith's and also glowed blue
when orcs or goblins were nearby another
name for it was goblin-cleaver
and the goblins called it biter both
blades had ork in their respective names
clawed blue and slayed goblins this is
just one example of how kuma pays homage
to Tolkien in his own fantasy novel fact
number six in my top 10 faction number
overlord video I let you guys know that
marui yama doesn't show his face
Mariama even went to anime expo wearing
a skeleton mask to hide his face even
though it was super hot
speaking of which Anime Expo 2018 was
also the first overseas convention that
cumo kagu went to it was also where
guests got a sneak preview of the Goblin
Slayer anime although I'm not sure if
kuhmo wore anything to cover his face at
the expo like midoriyama it is likely he
did since he usually does I could not
find his actual face on the Internet
but I did find him wearing what appears
to be a Deadpool mask a few times which
is pretty cool if you were at Anime Expo
and saw his panel definitely let us know
in the comments if you saw his actual
face or if not what kind of mask he had
fact number 7 along with classic fantasy
ku mole has admitted that he is a big
fan of tabletop RPGs like Dungeons &
Dragons and that he was heavily
influenced by these types of games as
well he even tells people that if they
are also fans of these games he strongly
recommends that they check out goblin
Slayer the scenes in the light novel
where gods are rolling dice to decide
the fates of the characters in the world
of goblin slayer seems to hint at this
influence as well it is as if the story
is positioning the players of Dungeons &
Dragons as gods and the world of goblin
Slayer is framed as if it was the game
that they are playing people have
noticed many similarities
for instance one goblin Slayer fan
pointed out that the adventure sheet
that priestess has to fill out is very
similar to a D&D sheet if you have any
other clear references to D&D and want
to share them feel free to put your
observations in the comments fact number
8 because this game is so heavily
influenced by tabletop or
PGs none of the characters have real
names rather they are named by their
class for instance goblin Slayers
childhood friend that he lives with is
simply called cowgirl while other
characters may simply be called warrior
or wizard because there are multiple
wizards in the world
you'll meet multiple characters named
wizard over the course of the story
let's just hope another goblin slayer
doesn't show up because then things may
start to get really confusing kuhmo
actually thought about giving the
characters proper names at one point but
ultimately decided against it in the
back of his mind he thought that all of
these characters were being played by
somebody on some tabletop RPG game so he
decided to let readers fill in the
blanks with their own names for the
characters let me know which character
you'd be if you could be anyone in
goblin slayer fact number 9 after this
fact the hitherto mentioned Deadpool
masks will suddenly start to make more
sense
Kumal has said along with being a fan of
Lord of the Rings and Dungeons and
Dragons he is also a big fan of American
comic books like my hero academia
creator Kohei horikoshi
and like horikoshi kuhmo was inspired by
the american comics he read in fact he
said that the motif of goblin slayer
came from american comics like Batman
The Punisher and more recently movies
like kick-ass instead of a kind of hero
who saves the world like Superman Goblin
flare is like this small-time hero that
isn't all that powerful who defeats the
local criminals and thugs he says he
wrote the story as if a Superman like
character exists already but on the side
there is the goblin Slayer doing his own
thing this is probably my favorite fact
and one of my favorite things about
goblin Slayer I absolutely love the fact
that he's not trying to be a Superman
and doesn't care what other people think
he's just doing what he feels is the
right thing to do doing the jobs that
those who are seeking glory and fame
won't fact number 10 you may well have
noticed that goblin Slayers armor is
pretty beat up and this includes his
helmet what you may not have known
that his helmet used to have horns like
that of a bull jutting out from each
side when goblin slayer was still a
greenhorn pun intended he lost them
the first horn was ripped off by a
goblin during his first goblin slaying
mission then instead of ripping the
other one off himself he does his goblin
slaying business for a while with one
horn then surprise surprise
another goblin rips off the other horn
then the goblin slayer losing all his
horns including his green one realizes
that maybe it's not a good idea having
horns for goblins to use as handlebars
and decides to go hornless from then on
and for a bonus fact you may not know
but on youtube you can also find a rare
interview with kuhmo on joeys aka the
anime man's channel he also starts off
that interview wearing his signature
Deadpool mask and there's a lot of good
and interesting stuff there so you
definitely should check it out link in
the description that interview was an
invaluable resource for this video since
it is probably the only interview with
kuhmo that you can find at this time my
personal favorite parts of the interview
were how unreal the goblin Slayer
success felt for kuhmo and his advice to
aspiring writers which was and I quote
just keep on writing and finish what you
started if you continue to do that over
and over it will eventually lead to
something I think that's actually great
advice for anything you want to do and
if it's not writing just substitute
writing for whatever your passion is
additionally I'll link the official
goblin Slayer Twitter account in the
description if you want to check out
some extra goblin Slayer material the
first tweet dates back to 2016 and it
translates to I will not save the world
I just slay goblins isn't that just the
best line ever and you can also check
out plenty of fanservice images over
there on the official Twitter if that
floats your goblin slaying vessel and
that is it for today's video guys thank
you so much for watching definitely slay
that like button if you enjoyed the
video and want to see more goblin Slayer
content on this
channel also if you haven't make like
the subscribe button was green and like
the magic youth do Bell just ripped off
the horn from your helmet thank you so
much for watching I really appreciate it
and until next time see you space
cowgirl
[Music]